What I'm talking about is something that
will take a generation to do what I need
to start there is that if we're looking
for a healthcare fix for something as
complex,
uh,
with,
with the previous choices we've made in
healthcare,
that's going to have a fundamental
impact on our system.
It's hopeless to too many of us depend
on the current forms of financing.
I have spent our whole lives
participating in it for an instantaneous
change and frankly the whole healthcare
industry,
which is almost a fifth of our economy,
has been set up with an existing system.
So the first thing you need is a
generation commitment.
I,
it's taken roughly 50 years to create
this mess.
You're not going to solve it in 12.
You're really gonna have to be committed
to fundamental change over time.
That's a very hard thing for our,
or frankly any political system to do
other than accidentally we did it
accidentally with Medicare and Medicaid
and,
and company funded insurance to do it
intentionally as much harder,
but that,
that's number one.
It's just a realistic sense of what it's
going to take.
Beyond that.
I think there are really three important
elements.
Number One,
I believe,
uh,
and I think many Americans do that there
really does need to be a true cradle to
grave safety net for all Americans for
catastrophic health,
which is really the initial starting
point of many of these debates in some
cases over a hundred years ago in the
developed world.
We still don't have that and I think I
think at two,
one will be up to near two and a half
trillion dollars of spending next year.
The number one question we need to ask
ourselves is how on earth do we spend
two and a half trillion dollars on
healthcare a year and not have a true
safety net for health catastrophes?
For All Americans?
That's number one.
And to me what that's about is
catastrophic insurance.
It actually is an insurable good.
Unlike so much of what is uninsured and
healthcare,
and I start there and it needs to be a
national pool because we can't get into
the situation.
We see now when we have private
insurance insurers competing for profit
growth in part on how successful they
are on underwriting out the worst cases.
We can't just let the public pay for the
worst cases.
It's actually an extraordinarily
inflationary approach to creating an
insurance.
But we need a national poll.
Beyond that though,
we have to look at funding non
catastrophic care,
which does include late life care
because it's plannable,
right?
Unlike most insurance events,
it's,
it's something that we can plan during
our life and that we do fund during our
life,
uh,
but also a lot of disease management
issues and frankly a lot of routine care
in the ways we fund other things in our
economy.
How do we do that?
We do that out of income,
out of savings,
out of credit against future savings.
And so what I would like to see over
time is a shift in the enormous
resources that we currently pay to
support the insurance system back to
consumers to allow them both to fund
their current,
uh,
medical expenses and save for future.
Once it has a couple of benefits.
Benefit number one is it returns us to
our role as consumers.
Uh,
it,
it does something.
We have to start with one,
I think now,
uh,
indisputable fact,
which is our 50 year reliance on
employers and insurers on governments to
control costs have failed,
right?
W W we will hear endless details of how
we can do it better in this odd,
this new regulation will finally do it.
But if you follow the last 50 years of
healthcare,
we've tried a lot of different things
that Medicare,
medicaid,
and private insurance and that theory,
that big will exercise,
leverage and leverage will keep prices
down.
You know,
if 50 years of the past experience
hasn't taught us,
that doesn't work,
then I guess we'll need more years.
But I,
I at least not many others believe at
some point you say,
okay,
this doesn't work.
What will.
Well,
the one thing we really haven't tried is
to do what works everywhere else,
which is to have a mass of desegregated
thinking consumers,
uh,
pushing prices,
forcing quality,
forcing accountability.
That's number one.
I,
I do want to come back to criticisms
with that approach because I think
there's some important criticisms of
that approach,
but that is,
you know,
where I start the second is we have to
avoid the use it or lose it.
Approach to financing healthcare and
reliance on insurance and on government
programs means that every dollar we put
into the system is going to be spent on
healthcare.
If you think about an individual's own
life,
uh,
you save money for rainy days,
but if it doesn't rain,
you may not apply an umbrella.
The healthcare system doesn't quite work
that way,
right?
Once a lot of the money we take from
people to pay for insurance premiums,
medicare tax,
a medicare premiums down the road is in
case you need it.
But the very fact it's there means it
will be spent on healthcare.
Now from an individual's perspective,
that may seem irrelevant,
but from a society's perspective,
it's a real problem because at coming up
very soon or 20 percent of GDP,
the dollars we're spending on healthcare
are things we can't spend on.
The other good things in life,
and you may be aware of my article,
I talk about how we don't even know if
we're making the the expenditures that
are best for our health.
We just know we're making the
expenditures that provide the most
health care.
Those are different things.
Nobody can answer the question,
would we as a society be better off all
giving each ourselves another week
vacation?
We're spending another 150 billion on
healthcare.
They're almost treated differently,
but they're not different.
Of course we're at a point in our health
where over 50 percent of annual deaths
come from conditions or causes that have
more to do with lifestyle.
Uh,
this is of course heart disease,
diabetes,
accident,
suicide,
homicide.
Then they have to do with health care.
We've done a great job in healthcare to
get to that point.
But being at that point,
if we're interested in improving our
health,
we don't know that these investments are
better made in healthcare or all the
other aspects of health,
whether it's recreation or environment
or nutrition or what have you,
that are being crowded out by society's
decision to fund healthcare in a use it
or lose it way.
So this is less important for the
individual,
perhaps more important for us as a
society.
So what I'm seeking to do is I'm seeking
to say rather than look for a magic
bullet,
single way to finance health care,
which I think comes out of that early
misconception I talked about that
healthcare is sort of a lump emergency.
Need it,
we know what it is,
pay for it.
That's not true anymore.
It's much more complex than that.
We need to match the way we finance
healthcare to how we use it to what it
is.
There are emergencies that are
catastrophic.
Uh,
not all of us will have them.
It's completely appropriate for
insurance to finance them.
Insurance is actually the most efficient
way to finance them.
Insurance that the least efficient,
most costly,
most distorted way of financing
everything else.
The first one is just a financial one,
which is people saying,
I can't afford it.
I have enough trouble affording my
deductible.
And they are right.
The key to this is that generational
shift I talk about every year.
We need to reduce a bit our reliance on
insurance and take some of the resources
we use to pay those premiums and get
them to consumers.
We need to gradually over a 20 year
period increased the deductible
insurance policies from what they are
now to general catastrophic.
What that will do is it will move more
healthcare resources to individuals,
uh,
enabling them to finance their care.
Now,
the only good news about spending two
and a half trillion dollars on
healthcare is that all of us,
and I mean all of us are spending an
incredible amount of money on care.
We may not be aware of it.
We may think somebody else is paying for
it.
That's an illusion.
You know,
one of things I looked at it in my
article was hire higher 23 year old
today and he spends his entire career
with my company and he has a spouse and
a couple of kids and a few years and
retires at 65 and lives to lady,
um,
and what would the amount of money that
goes into the system for that 23 year
old and started them at entry level
salary $30,000 a year,
uh,
which is roughly 60 percent of the
average household income in our country.
And had him grow that his income grow at
three percent over the course of his
life,
gets a salary,
have little over $100,000 by retires.
And I made an assumption which hasn't
been true for 50 years,
which is let's say the growth of all
healthcare is only equal to the growth
of income,
of course has been running one or two
points above income.
The amazing thing is that 23 year old is
looking at one point $7,
million dollars being spent on his or
her behalf to fund his household,
had medical care over their lives.
That's everything that's,
uh,
their own share of,
of,
uh,
health insurance,
their out of pocket.
Um,
uh,
their medicare premiums when they're
seniors,
the stuff that they actually see,
but it's also the stuff they don't see
what their employer paid on their
behalf.
The Medicare tax that came out.
Um,
and uh,
um,
uh,
what's interesting is I realized later
that I understated it because I didn't
include the amount of general tax
revenues that subsidizing our
healthcare,
which is another big bite.
But let's,
let's forget that for a moment.
I think if you said to the average 23
year old,
you want to participate in this
insurance system,
or you want a million dollars over your
life to spend on your own care,
and if you don't spend it on your own
care,
uh,
you can put it away.
The only thing I'm,
I ask you to do is I'm going to insist
you buy catastrophic insurance.
I don't think there's any question what
the average 23 year old and say now you
say an average 23 year old may not be
smart enough to make that decision or
longterm,
but let's look at the impact on
everybody in this country have a
healthcare system that costs the average
employer who pays insurance 12 grand a
year per employee 12 grand.
So if you're earning the average income
in this country,
$50,000,
your employer is paying $62,000 was
forget about social security tax and
Medicare tax,
a moment for the privilege of employing
you and you're getting only 50 grand.
That is an extraordinary aggressive tax.
The interesting thing is if you
transferred that 12 grand to the average
family,
they could buy catastrophic care for the
whole family and have a significant
amount of money,
leftover savings,
the health savings account or per year.
So you have to be willing to do both.
You have to be willing to reduce the
coverage of insurance,
but transfer those resources to
individuals and if you're not willing to
do both and people would be afraid that
you are.
Of course,
the you can't have a consumer driven
system.
The second concern I think a lot of
people have is consumers aren't wise
enough or smart enough or capable of
driving pricing and quality in our
healthcare system,
and I think as a lot of fundamental
reforms have to deal with that seems to
be comparing a proposed new approach was
something that doesn't exist today.
Consumers make all the decisions on
their healthcare today.
Not the negative ones,
but you can't.
You can't treat somebody without their
choosing the treatment without they're
agreeing to the treatment.
I'm not proposing getting rid of
doctors.
I'm not saying let's take the
professionals who advise you now out of
the system and you design your own
treatment and find someone to do it.
What I'm saying is right now we have a
system where doctors advise a patients
make the ultimate decisions subject to
insurance company via.
I am removing the insurance company from
that equation,
but I don't think that most consumers
would say,
well,
that puts me in a terrible position.
I rely on my insurance company to help
me through my life self care decisions
there.
There's another thing that I think again
comes out of the island nature of health
care.
Very few of us are true active
comparative shoppers and everything we
buy.
We all benefit from the existence of
Walmart,
whether we shop there or have ever in
our lives compare the price of
toothpaste.
What happens in a consumer driven
economy isn't that every consumer after
getting hit by the bus,
goes to the Internet and calls up a
emergency surgeons to see who to hire
and at what price.
What happens is is you benefit from the
fact that the entire structure of
providers is altered to attract
consumers as opposed to serve insurers
and governments.
That's the.
That's the dynamic I'm trying to capture
in a consumer centric approach.
That dynamic of providers who answer to
us patient consumers and not to
intermediaries,
and if you spend time in a hospital
watching a patient be treated,
not for a second,
can you forget that that patient isn't
the customer of that hospital.
Can't forget it.
You see it in the care in almost every
element of the care and if you've been
in the rest of our economy and bought
anything in the rest of the economy,
you know,
that's true.
Nowhere else.
And that's a crucial thing.
I'm not sure there are,
there are many.
Um,
I think some of the objectives,
uh,
that we've talked about today are things
that people are increasingly aware may
matter a in resolving this sort of trap
we're in,
of ever reducing access ever lower
quality and ever higher prices.
I think one of them is there's an
awareness that a lack of competition and
a lack of price transparency makes it
difficult for consumers to exercise,
um,
any of the disciplinary force they do in
most other industries.
There's been a movement in some states,
certainly for greater price
transparency.
Unfortunately it's not true price
transparency is list price and of course
hospitals don't charge this price for
anything.
Um,
so it's been fairly meaningless,
but it's a step.
It's an understanding of,
of the right direction.
One of the interesting things that's
occurring,
and we've seen it occur and other
government programs as well,
is that there is the beginnings of
something of a shadow economy and
healthcare for people who are outside
the system,
uh,
for many of those who either don't have
access to health insurance or can't
afford health insurance.
Um,
there is increasingly a cash and credit
based economy around health care
services.
There are parts of this country you can
drive around and see services advertised
on billboards on a cash only basis.
Um,
you obviously see some of these clinics
that have opened in walmarts and cvs is,
they'd get at one of the,
uh,
you know,
one of the things you would expect to
see in a more consumer oriented system,
which has real value services,
uh,
for some of the less complex,
a more easy to replicate a treatment,
uh,
possibilities such as it is many in
primary care.
Um,
but I think we have to be,
we have to be candid about the walls
around the political process.
Now,
the reality is most Americans are happy
with their health insurance.
And I think some pulsate it's 55 or 60
percent,
uh,
and probably a percentage of those who
have health insurance,
it may even be higher and as long as
that's the case,
we're not going to expect any politician
to propose fundamental reform.
They can't.
There are enormous interest groups,
uh,
that existed in the,
in the provision of healthcare,
um,
who would be opposed to anything that
negative that affects the status quo
negatively from them.
And obviously anything we had real
discipline on price would negatively
affect the status quo for these interest
groups.
No politician's going to buck that for a
public that believes it's got a good
deal at 55 or 60 percent approval.
You can't go at the fundamental of the
system.
One of the things that I,
I mentioned in my article and the
reasons I spent a lot of time on numbers
is that I think this is actually an
illusion.
I think much of healthcare policy has
been about perpetuating this illusion
that somebody else's magically paying
for your care.
Uh,
one of things I talk about is a very
common among my fellow liberals is to
say,
well,
if we eliminated advertising and we
eliminated the profit motive in order
things I mentioned in my,
in my articles,
if you confiscated the profits of every
single American company,
forget about the drug companies and the,
and the hospital companies and the
device manufacture.
Just take every prophet,
every dollar of profit in the American
economy.
You'd pay for something like four or
five months of our healthcare in two and
a half trillion dollars.
We're not there yet.
We'll be there next year.
I think the number of this year is
likely to be somewhere between two,
three to four,
but two and a half trillion dollars.
The only people who can pay for
healthcare is all of us and we're all
paying for an enormous amounts,
right?
You hear people talk all the time.
And I,
one of the reasons I,
I,
uh,
have so few friends left,
is one of the things I do at dinner
parties is talk about,
I asked people to mention a healthcare
bill I have and I break it down,
what do you think the costs of that are?
But you'll see a $5,000 bill for
something that probably had five or $600
and marginal cost,
uh,
and you'll recognize just how
extraordinary the inflation is,
but you'll also recognize that what your
friend was worried about was the three
or $400 they had to pay against it.
And,
um,
you know,
the difference in that is costing us all
a fortune.
The moment at which everybody says,
you know,
it's kind of like having a credit card.
I can go out and buy a $2,000 plasma
television,
not pay for it at that moment and tell
myself,
hey,
this plasma tv costs me nothing.
It's the damn credit card bill.
It's costing me a fortune.
That's what we've done in healthcare.
Um,
and unfortunately we have divided the
funding among so many different places,
right?
Ourselves.
Um,
our,
uh,
our employer in many cases,
various targeted taxes,
the government general revenues that
people don't sit there and say,
wow,
the average middle class family is
probably looking at 20,
30 percent of their income,
somebody somewhere taking out and paying
for healthcare.
That's extraordinarily regressive.
And I think if there's awareness of that
or when there's awareness of that and it
may take more time and more spending and
more afraid,
safety net and frankly more people
suffering and being hurt,
uh,
for us to get the realization that there
is no free ride in healthcare,
it's costing us a fortune and we're all
being hurt by the lack of discipline in
the system.
I think only then you'll look at the
true fundamental reform being
politically possible for politicians to
take the enormous political risk of
saying to some of the interest groups in
health care.
I'm sorry,
but the pie hasn't been.
Again.